hey 42 here most children in the West
are brought up being told that a jolly
fat magic man delivers their presents
every year but as we grow older and
wiser we start to think that that maybe
isn't the whole truth and the
disappearing mince pie in brandy has a
lot more to do with your actual father
than father Christmas
but naysay is I'm here to present a
different point of view and go with me
on this one what if Santa Claus is real
well he could be and I'm not talking
about magic but actual science what
happens when we apply maths formulas and
the laws of motion to a large man with a
brandy addiction but surely it's
impossible for one man to deliver
millions of presents to millions of
homes in just one night not to mention
the flying reindeer and sweatshop style
elves well depending on how naughty
you've been this year you might be
pleasantly surprised let's take a look
at the actual physics behind Santa Claus
and find out if we shouldn't be so quick
to disbelieve in a very old Christmas
legend so one of the major issues that
people have with the big cave Kringle is
that he couldn't possibly visit every
house on earth in one night but the
thing is he doesn't have to to start
with he reportedly only visits children
of which there are two billion of on
earth that's people under the age of 18
the average children per household
across the world is roughly 3.5 so that
leaves 1 billion households for Santa to
visit on Christmas Eve and it's commonly
been accepted throughout history that
Santa doesn't visit children of
non-christian religions such as Muslim
Jewish Hindu and Buddhist so if we
factor out those households that leaves
us with only 92 million homes for Santa
to visit that's significantly less also
Santa doesn't have to fit these all into
24 hours on Christmas Eve if he travels
from east to west then he would have 31
hours in which to deliver presents
thanks to time zone differences
this leaves Santa with roughly one
thousandth of a second to get down the
chimney deliver presents and consume
whatever treats have been left out for
him he would have to make eight hundred
and twenty two visits per second a
challenge indeed and that brings us to
the ever so complicated topic of flying
reindeer and I know what you're thinking
you ain't never gonna prove them to me
mister forty two well consider this
there are an estimated 300 thousand
species of living organisms yet to be
classified on earth and there exists a
bleedin snake that can fly so who are we
to say that there aren't flying reindeer
somewhere out there argue of that logic
why don't but one of the biggest
obstacle stopping Santa from being real
is not magical deer but the payload he
would have to carry even if every child
only receives a small toy from Santa
around 800 grams on average it would
result on a payload on Santa's sleigh
weighing three hundred and two million
kilograms and that's not even counting
all the coal for all the terrible little
Horrors out there now consider that
Santa would have to travel at six
hundred and fifty miles per second to
get around all the required households
on time for Christmas morning three
hundred and two million kilograms
traveling at that speed would exert a
read no shuttering 13.5 quintillion
joules of energy on each and every
reindeer due to the immense air pressure
created out sort of speeds at those
pressures blitzen's going to get Blitzen
come it will turn into an actual comet
in short Santa his sleigh and his
reindeer would burst into a ball of
flames and perish instantaneously after
setting off from the North Pole
so yeah Merry Christmas but hold on kids
wipe away those tears because 42 backed
up by some scientific papers he just
read is about to save Christmas the
strange science of quantum mechanics
allows for some physics defying
spectacles that seem to defy every
scientific law you thought you knew
and if we apply the laws of quantum
mechanics to Santa Claus then it's
possible that here's a macroscopic
quantum object now this would allow him
to be in multiple places at once meaning
he could deliver presents to every child
on earth simultaneously there's also the
added benefit that he can keep an eye on
mrs. Claus whilst he's away for the
night which is imperative after elf gate
of Christmas Eve 1984 quantum mechanics
is a branch of science that studies the
very very small sub atomic particles it
is our current understanding that these
tiny particles such as electrons can be
in two or more places in the universe at
the exact same time as one Gaz nobody is
watching to prove this scientists fired
a single particle into an opaque plate
that had two slits in it the diffraction
pattern on the other side of the plate
revealed that this singular particle
actually passed through both slits at
the same time however when detectors
were set up to monitor if the particle
pass through each slit it's only passed
through one slit at a time but never
both just because it was being watched
now to put this as simply as possible
this happens because the particle
wavefunction collapses when it is being
observed
so it can no longer be in two places at
once it's similar to how mrs. Claus can
be in a different place and she's
supposed to be when Santa's not watching
now this explains why Santa Claus can
never be seen because if he were to be
seen his wavefunction would collapse so
if this is true how could we know Santa
is a large jolly fellow and not an
itty-bitty little subatomic particle
well scientists have observed large
clusters of particles now seem to behave
as one single particle admittedly these
clusters of particles are nowhere near
as large as our prospective mr. Claus
but have some imagination for goodness
sake so if Santa and his reindeer are a
cluster of billions and billions of
particles acting together as one then he
caught
ethically still adhere to the laws of
quantum mechanics and deliver lovely
gifts to deserving children all over the
world in just one night
this would also explain why his
super-secret Bond villain death star
base of toy construction is tucked away
in the North Pole because quantum
particles only behave in this manner in
very very cold environments now
scientists have only observed this
behavior at close to absolute zero minus
273 degrees Celsius which admittedly is
somewhat colder than the North Pole but
then again we have to allow for some
magic on Christmas don't we thanks for
watching then you could be an
extraordinarily intelligent person
possibly even genius-level do you ever
get the feeling that people are talking
about you behind your back well that's
because they are